coleman reports from faye herron
elementary school
majority of the bills signed by governor
sisolak are signed in carson city
but this morning he signed several right
here at this elementary school in north
las vegas
these students that are here behind me
are the reason we do what we do
they are the reason that this
legislation was written
lobbied for and passed into law if you
could join me once more giving them a
huge round of applause because they're
outstanding
efforts to help nevada families and
students the future
of the silver state the governor signed
the senate bill 173
known as the back on track act helping
districts address learning loss
stem from the pandemic and ensures no
child slips through the cracks
senate bill 249 allows a mental or
behavioral health professional the
ability to certify an excused absence
for a student
senate bill 450 will bring classrooms
into the 21st century
providing funding to build 13 new
schools and renovate 33 existing schools
and finally bill 495 took compromise
implementing a 1 percent tax on the 12th
largest industry in nevada
mining it is about our most valuable
resource here in nevada
not the gold not the silver but the
children of nevada
and 8495 really links mining
with education ab4 95 will provide more
than 200 million dollars
towards education reporting in north las
vegas bianca holman
8 news now